so here you are you take a lemon cut it
in half squeeze it in your water
disregard the peel from the garbage and
then you drink your lemon water thinking
you're getting
all these amazing nutrients but did you
realize that the peel the white part
which is called the pith and the seeds
have five times
more nutrition
than the juice in the pulp when you hear
what i'm going to talk about the
benefits of using the whole lemon
you will never waste the peel again so
let me explain
typically lemons are loaded with vitamin
c unless it's pasteurized and you're
consuming
like lemon juice from some bottle
so if it's pasteurized it's heated
there's hardly any vitamin c unless they
add it in there
but there is potassium magnesium b6
b1
b2 there's copper there's vitamin e
and if you use actual fresh lemon you'll
get vitamin c which i'm going to cover
i've done quite a few videos on the
benefits of lemon water specifically
reducing fat on your liver
reducing cholesterol
helping you lose weight because you're
making insulin more sensitive and you're
addressing insulin resistance the
benefits of anti-aging the benefits of
lemon for anti-cancer there are very
specific compounds in lemons that
can help kill cancer cells and the
benefits of lemons for kidney stone
prevention especially if you're on the
ketogenic diet and you're prone to
kidney stones and then the benefit of
vitamin c for your immune system and
also how lemon can inhibit
collagen destruction but if you actually
consume
the white part of the lemon and the
outer peel
and the seeds you're going to get some
additional very cool benefits that i
want to educate you on now the first
thing i want to cover is vitamin c
vitamin c deficiency is related to
something called scurvy okay where you
lose your collagen your joints you have
a lot of fatigue and you might say that
scurvy doesn't exist now but i think
there's subclinical versions of scurvy
that people have and they don't even
really know that they had it but in the
30s
scientists have
found that using straight ascorbic acid
which is considered vitamin c which it's
really not
it's just one part of the vitamin c
complex
they found that using ascorbic acid does
not work as well as using the whole
vitamin c complex
from lemons paprika or oranges in other
words they found some other additional
things in the whole fruit like lemons
that are not in ascorbic acid and so
back in the 30s
they identified vitamin p okay now they
don't call it vitamin p anymore because
typically vitamins fulfill a certain
criteria and vitamin p does not fulfill
that criteria
but vitamin p stands for permeability as
in vascular permeability or
capillary permeability or microvascular
permeability
now permeability is basically the
ability
of your vascular system
to
allow things to move in and out between
the vascular system and so there are
various gaps that occur and when you
have too much of a gap you have symptoms
like bleeding gums
like gingivitis you might get
spider veins varicose veins
hemorrhoids which involve the veins
you might get bruising you might get a
bleeding nose or edema so they found
this p factor okay vitamin p
helps to tighten up those junctions
those gaps
and prevents all these symptoms so the p
factor is really part of the vitamin c
complex that's in nature so typically in
nature you don't just have ascorbic acid
you have ascorbic acid which is a the
antioxidant portion
you have also the p factor which is
really the bioflavonoids and there's
about eight thousand different
bioflavonoids in certain plant compounds
and what i'm going to talk about is the
citrus
bioflavonoids these bioflavonoids are
part of the vitamin c complex the other
parts of the vitamin c complex would be
the j factor or vitamin j
another thing that i'm not going to get
into now but vitamin j helps
increase the oxygenation in your lungs
they help it helps you breathe better
and then you also have
copper in the vitamin c complex in an
enzyme form called tyrosinase
and that copper is really important in
collagen formation this is why vitamin c
is so good for collagen
joint health etc and then you also have
vitamin k1 which is part of the vitamin
c complex as well which also helps to
prevent bleeding and things like that
because vitamin k1 is involved with
clotting so when you're consuming
the white part in the outside part
of the lemon or limes you are getting a
tremendous amount of this extra
vitamin p or let's just call it the
bioflavonoids
which can really help you in many
different ways including some additional
things for the eye i mean think about
what happens in with diabetes you have a
lot of damage
in the capillaries you have damage in
the nervous system because the
capillaries are no longer feeding the
nerves so you get peripheral neuropathy
you have a lot of problems of the eye
as in diabetic retinopathy in diabetes
you have macular degeneration you get
cataracts you get glaucoma dry eyes and
so you have a lot of leaking of blood
through the capillaries in the eye
caused by the destruction of the high
glucose but if you're a diabetic
and you actually take these
bioflavonoids from lemons you can
greatly reduce the complications that
occur from diabetes and this incredible
oxidation that is just destroying your
capillary system now here's what i'm
going to recommend that you do and you
just need to try this once to see
and once you try this you're going to
like it you're going to feel good and
you're going to want to do this every
day
one lemon you're going to blend it okay
make sure the lemon is an organic lemon
i would blend the whole thing seeds and
all unless the seeds bother your stomach
some people um they might find that they
have a sensitivity or gastritis in their
stomach and so they might take the seeds
out but there's a lot of nutrition in
these seeds they're not poisonous like
eating cherry seeds or apricot seeds
things like that the seeds from lemons
or limes are totally fun so what you do
is you simply take eight ounces of water
one cup of water
put in the blender
take the whole lemon
and blend it on down for probably 30
to 45 seconds okay
it will make this whitish drink okay
that's very very bitter so you know it's
good for the liver
and especially a fatty liver not to
mention your skin
and giving you all these other great
benefits now to offset the bitterness
i usually like to use
liquid stevia drops
and depending on your taste you might
want to try just five drops and see if
that's sufficient or some people like it
a little bit sweeter so put up to 10
drops so between 5 and ten drops okay
and then just slug it down it's actually
quite delicious now you can also use
instead of stevia frozen blueberries
okay you mix a cup of blueberries frozen
with your lemon blend it on down it
makes a delicious lemon blueberry shake
so try this every day not just for a
fatty liver but to get the extra
benefits
of the so-called waste product of lemons
that most people are disregarding just
because they don't know all the amazing
bio flavonoid benefits from the whole
lemon now if you haven't seen my popular
video on lemon water yet
i put it right here check it out
you